ja wir spielen heute einen kutscher
simulator
ich kann einfach alles an kotzen und
damit herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einem neuen video meine sehr verehrten
freunde das hier ist jeff und chef
marcus hotze in der presse zu haben und
jetzt ist er verschwunden
das ist nämlich der komplette sinn des
spiels flugsimulator dass die brigitte
da können wir auch mal hier komplett
hier übrigen bleibt doch stehen ja da
ist er weg
brigitte ist auch weg da kommt diese man
tschüs es die will ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich weiß nicht was diese spielhilfe
einsender ich habe es verweise team
gekauft und auch was kann ich denn ich
habe sogar einen stern alter dass herr
wie gta nur mit kotze also puke
simulator steht ja oh mein gott
das ist nicht wahr das ist wie bei das
ist wie bei ford neid die die reifen das
spiel heißt halt wirklich proxim later
also kotze simulator ich kann über diese
teile kann ich herumspringen
also wählt ob wir sind in einer riesigen
stadt mein gott was ist denn das unser
heutiges ziel ist es da oben hinzukommen
nicht erinnert das ganze so ein bisschen
ein golfsimulator nur dass wir nicht ein
[Musik]
ich kenne auch hey du bist ja zurück das
bisschen wieder weg also was ich sagen
wollte mich erinnert das spiel
tatsächlich ein bisschen einen
golfsimulator dass wir keine ziegel sind
sondern ein kotzen dass etwas und dass
wir in einer first person spielen und
soll ich eigentlich wieder gut simulator
hochladen last einen leiter und 13
kommentare favorisiert dieses video und
abonniert main kanal wenn ihr noch nicht
teil der lupo seit als motto spaß die da
jetzt mario vier freunde ich weiß nicht
was ich jetzt genau machen muss jetzt
ein auto das hat den unfall kann ich das
irgendwie löschen ich habe noch was zu
tun dann kann der mal aufhören mich hier
die ganze zeit um zu fahren
wir müssen erstmal gucken was hier so
abgeht mikey way to the end of the world
steht ja ok das sieht nach einem mini
game aus sagt hier hoch springen dann
das ist natürlich blöd versuchen immer
zwei freude diesmal versuche ich hier
nicht irgendwie ins wasser zu fallen
also ich versucht relativ schnell nach
vorne zu gehen genau und jetzt auch das
ist doch nicht wahr
wieso geht er nicht nach vorn immer an
das spiel ist tatsächlich schwieriger
als ich gedacht habe
komm alter das ist doch das ist doch
einfach scheiße das komische plattform
spiel ist mir scheißegal
hier sind wir auf jeden fall vorhin
gespannt erwarten dass ich habe ach du
scheiße
ist das ja kommt da baut sich einfach
außen nicht setzen labyrinth hierauf ich
glaube jetzt die ganze zeit durch dieses
labyrinth plötzlichen ausweg finden oder
was ein paar sekunden später
onlive heck also ich bin ganz ehrlich
dieses spiel das ich hey so was ist der
sinn von diesem spiel naja also stand
bei steam als der kurze simulator glaubt
da brauche ich keine großen hoffnungen
haben yun ok
ich habe einfach nicht getroffen mit der
katze was bedeutet überhaupt meine
spende da oben also das verstehe ich
auch nicht so ganz so was kann ich hier
machen wollen war jedoch im hoch
er sieht ein bisschen verstört aus was
passiert wenn ich den vorstand kommen so
steht mittlerweile gar nichts mehr was
passiert denn wenn ich einfach mal
richtig richtig viel kotze also wirklich
so dass das spiel quasi nahezu abspülen
einfach mal die polizeistation vor
kurzem jahr menschenskinder sagt mir
doch einfach was ich jetzt machen soll
kann ich unten rein gehen
dieses verdammte scheiße ernst was soll
ich denn hier machen hier sind überall
nur so kleine wege da sind überall leute
hier unten kann ich nirgendwo hin das
spiel da hinten habe ich nicht geschafft
hier sind überall wo ich kann nichts
machen man jedoch weg alter let's have
is mit picknick also hier muss ich jetzt
gerade innerhalb von einer gewissen zeit
die ganzen snacks einsammeln die
irgendwie schön dass wir julis absolutes
traumspiel leute ich krieg hier wirklich
die komplette volk wie sie mir wird
schwindelig ich sage hier einfach
irgendwelche dummen snacks ein alter was
geht denn ok und was bringt mir das
jetzt also ich weiß wirklich nicht was
das ja alles soll es ist einfach eine
map mit verschiedenen typs core die
highspeed das heißt ich muss so viele
leute wie möglich irgendwie ankotzen
dass die hindernisse also dass die halt
irgendwie diskutieren und dafür bekomme
ich dann pumpe ich meine leute was ist
euer kopf heiß vor so
a
kein problem also jetzt mal ganz ehrlich
meine aufgabe ist es gerade so viele
leute wie möglich anzupassen so dass ich
punkte bekomme und dadurch meinen high
score steigere
dieses spiel ist im wahrsten sinne des
wortes zum kotzen 26 polizei ach du
heilige scheiße
ach du heilige scheiße ich hab drei
sterne
man denkt sich so ja man entspannter tag
machen einen spaziergang aber 20.000
polizisten verfolgt mich hier kann ich
mein gott ich habe
ich habe alle
oh mein gott
ich habe mich erschrocken
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich habe wirklich bei steam
gesehen der kurze simulator ich habe mir
gesagt hey das passt zu mir meinen kanal
und meinem content ist eigentlich
ziemlich traurig las eine like da wenn
es euch gefallen hat freunde schreibt
mir und in die kommentare ob ich das
noch mal spielen soll
oder halt mal gold simulator wieder ab
hiess weltfrieden betet dafür dass es
mehr alpakas gibt die uns pizzas bringen
das bin ich ein mensch
[Musik]